welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and he now locked
into the channel where we break down all
the latest movies new game releases TV
shows and comic books with the 3rd
episode of Star Wars the Mandalorian out
on Disney Plus it's time to go back to a
long time ago in a galaxy far far away
throughout this video we'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the new episodes overall plot and
its ending to discuss what could be
happening in the future there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch episode 3 yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for breakdowns like this every day and
weekly coverage on the Mandalorian I
have spoken without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into our
breakdown of the Mandalorian okay so
just a quick catch up on what's been
going on so far in the show the
Mandalorian was tasked to travel to a
planet and retrieve what is the cutest
baby way B in the entire universe and
after a couple of trials and
tribulations mando managed to get the
prize and escorted off the planet but
there was something different about this
bounty baby Yoda as it's being called on
the Internet is strong with the force
and through their journey mando and the
child have bonded with one another mando
himself who as a child had his life torn
away sees this reflected in the young
Ling who soon will have theirs taken to
episode three titled the sin picks up
with mando returning to the client but
it looks like he gains separation
anxiety and the episode very much deals
with the character struggling with his
duty and protecting the little baby we
stand for baby Yoda to me the sin itself
refers to the fact that mando aka Dan
Joran sins in the episode by handing
over the innocent character there's a
metaphor for rebirth in the piece that
has almost a sort of baptism and it's
during this point that a big change for
the character comes with him returning
to right the wrong at the beginning
we'll get into this later but there's a
strong sense at the scene in the episode
refers to mandos past in which he lived
selfishly and how his actions have
basically led to him committing this one
big sin but yeah there's a lot going on
in this episode that ties directly to
the title the opening kicks off with a
hologram come
in between Greek kaga and mondo that
sees the young baby just getting cuter
and cuter somehow I love the composition
of this shot and he sort of have an
angel and devil almost on the characters
shoulders with the two paths being
clearly labeled before him if last
week's episode was a video game side
quest then this one is definitely a Mass
Effect choose-your-own-adventure one and
having these two characters and opposite
sides of the screen cements the two
paths that Dinge Oren has ahead of him
as mando walks the client we see jours a
little astronaut thing that has the
sound of a probe droid coming from it
and of course the returning door guard
from the first episode that bears a
striking resemblance to the worn at
Jabba's palace the client seems
overjoyed to see the prize brought in
and we learn that he was also behind all
of the bounty hunters that mando has
come face-to-face with including IG 11
and the ones that he fought in the
desert he rewards mando with best car
steal but our protagonist once more
including what the client plans to do
with the child but we learn that asking
questions is against guild rules this
subtly starts the show that mando is
turning away from a sense of duty in
favour of doing the right thing which is
pretty much the arc that he goes on
throughout the episode mando returns to
the blacksmith and passes several others
of his kind the mythos or symbol returns
as well I touched on this last time but
I thought I'd go into more detail here
as its returned and has more prominence
for those who don't know mythos ores
were native creatures of Mandalore that
completely dominated the planet due to
their size the group that would become
known as the Mandalorians wished to gain
this planet for themselves
and thus they set out hunting these
giant beasts until they were extinct
hence the proud use of their skull as a
symbol of the race with the blacksmith
man no commissions to have new armor
made and I feel bad for everyone who's
already bought mando Funko pops cuz yeah
they're already out of date right now
there's been a couple of complaints
online that there's no women in the show
but at least we have the blacksmith who
is clearly a female we're all about
equality on this channel everyone let's
mention that the best gar Steel has
Empire markings on it and then it was
taken during the Great Purge that pretty
much wiped out their people it is
possible that this was during order 66
and there is currently online a lot of
speculation that the Empire
carried out the purge of the
Mandalorians alongside the Jedi one in
which they invaded Mandalore stealing
their supplies and resources to be used
on their weapons and battleships we see
flashes of this once more and it further
adds to the duality in this episode the
sin could also be a reference to this
purge in which man no is trying to own
by reclaiming the armor for himself now
in the flashback man no does come face
to face with the super battle droid from
the prequel trilogy which were not on
the Empire's side and they were pretty
much all wiped out by order 66 however
we know that Darth Sidious was behind
both sides so this could be how the
Empire obtained the rest deal it's also
possible that the Mandalorian purge in
order 66 are unrelated but whatever the
case it's clear that a lot of other
Mandalorians looked down on this move
and a fight breaks out between mando and
another mando refers to baby Yoda as an
enemy that helped him in a vowel and the
blacksmith asking why an enemy would
help him for me is the moment that it
all fits together in his mind and he
realizes that baby Yoda isn't the bad
guy and instead the group that ransacked
his home killed his family and took his
resources yeah yeah maybe they are
also on a side note we don't know the
name of baby ro just yet so I'm
referring to him just as that but make
sure you leave your thoughts and what
the name could be we know it starts with
a y like Yoda and yeah also so maybe
maybe baby Yolo that done this this
channel gets worse and worse
man no refuses the blacksmith's offer of
a mud horn Signet and instead gives him
one known as whistling birds which are a
powerful defense against multiple
enemies anyone want a group hug nope me
neither after getting his new skin
available on Star Wars Battlefront 2 as
a microtransaction for $4.99 I'm
guessing mana returns to grieve and asks
how many other bounty hunters were given
the task of hunting baby Oda grief
replies all of them which kind of
cements just how badly the client wanted
BY reef wants to party like it's $21.99
but mono just wants to put the job
behind him moving on from all of this
there's word of a nobleman skipping bail
on Karnak but I don't think we will get
much beyond this little Easter egg
that's a reference to ancient Egypt
maybe mando will team up with him down
the line but yeah I highly doubt it what
didn't Jordan really wants it now though
is what's going
having to the baby and though he tries
to leave a behind sing the knob that the
child picked off at the start of the
episode brings it all back he returns to
the clients headquarters and overhears
the client telling dr. Pershing that he
has to extract the necessary material
and then be done with it
now theory time here so we know from
eagle-eyed viewers that dr. Pershing has
the badge of kamino cloners on his
uniform and if you've been keeping up to
date with my channel and watched my baby
out a video then you know that this is
because I think they are planning to
clone the child personally I think this
cements this theory and whilst never
before has it been possible to replicate
force sensitive beings the extraction
could be referring to taking the child's
midi-chlorians and replicating them
before adding them back into either a
clone of baby Yoda or a completely new
being there's also some discussions
online that one of the big reasons that
Emperor Palpatine manages to return in
the rise of Skywalker is because they
extract the creatures midi-chlorians and
use them to re-energize his life force
but personally I'm leaning more with
this cloning theory especially due to
the uniform that dr. Pershing has when
coming face-to-face with the Mandalorian
Pershing says that he was keeping the
child protected and this does tie back
to the first episode in which he did
insist that it was brought back alive
personally I believe that this may be
due to the fact that it's easier to
clone a living creature over a dead one
and when something with the force dies
the force goes with it so this could be
the thinking behind that the Klein is
clearly keeping Pershing alive though so
should he fail it will likely be what
happens to most people who fail in the
Empire that's right McConkey Pershing is
probably a prisoner similar to most
scientists in the Empire and we saw this
play a massive part in rogue one in the
creation of the Death Star so he is
unlikely to be operating on kids for the
fun of it
mando escapes with a child and it
becomes very much John wick 3 with the
character having to get off the planet
with organs pointed on him for breaking
the code mando has when fully Rogue
rogue one at this point and the end of
the series looks like it's very much
going to be centered around him having
to protect the child and take out all of
those that have a target on his head
mono is not alone though and similar to
John wick he still has allies which
include his mana brethren
earlier who are probably told morally
Bert would much rather support their own
then let the Empire get their way
mono uses all of its arsenal to kill
those that come face to face with them
and in my opinion it's an absolutely
amazing action scene that shows just how
good stalls can be when it's done
correctly watching the bird group attack
flamethrowers and blasters being used in
combat is awesome and he finally gets
back to the races crest only to be
confronted by grief and his gang with
help from his allies mana makes it to
his ship and I loved watching them with
their jet packs on blasting the group
and this was pretty much a real version
of scenes that played out in my head as
a kid with my Bubba Fett and Jango Fett
action figures yeah I know they're not
real Mandalorians yet but still it still
counts yet this is the way I have spoken
an e ship mondo is confronted by grief
who shoots but grief survives due to
having Mandalorian steel over his heart
and with the help of Ironman DeLorean
baby odor and the titular character
escaped into space ending the episode
now going forward a thing that episode 4
might either center around mondo going
across the galaxy to get baby Yoda a new
crib or it could actually just show a
flashback to the purge and we get a full
episode of that this was clearly
happening during the Clone Wars if not
after it to do the super battle droid
and I would say that this was during one
of the major complex
I think episode 4 we'll fill in the
details of how mondo escaped coming gun
to face with a droid like this and we do
know that the Jedi were fighting the
droids during his time so we could see
an intervention by one of them to stop
the machine before it kills the
protagonist there's rumors online that
this could be obi-wan but personally I
don't know if we're ready to go that a
list with it yet however there is a
massive chance that a Jedi could save
him if nano is saved by a Jedi as well
it will explain why he was so torn on
baby Yoda and though in the last episode
he seemed unaware of the force this may
have forced see what I did there his
mind to recall that those that saved him
as a child with Jedi and now he has to
do the same thing for one of their young
ones it's all getting really interesting
and I'm absolutely loving the show at
the moment as this is ticking all the
right boxes for me and Disney are
knocking it out of the park with this
and fall in order I'm so hyped for Star
Wars and I can't wait to see what
happens next week now obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the Mandalorian
episode 3 as well that's what your
theories for the future are make sure
you leave them in the comment section
below because I'd love to read them and
if you enjoy this video please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you stay locked
at the channel for breakdowns of every
episode as they're released it's my
wife's birthday today as well and she's
letting me stay in to make this video so
yeah show some love with a like if you
want to watch us discuss more of the
series that make sure you check out our
full breakdown of the first two episodes
which would be linked at the end as we
go over everything you need to know
about the show all of the Easter eggs
and more so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want something else
to watch after this if you want to come
chat to me after the video that make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition white tea or head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free adjoin and we have
an awesome community so hopefully I see
you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the Marvel
phase 3 part 2 box on blu-ray which
contains Black Panther infinity war and
Game Captain Marvel and more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts and the mandalorian in the
comments section below but when it's
gonna be chosen on the 15th of December
and the Celt be shipped out from then
Topher gets the prize it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to Definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]